the opening scene features a high school
girl named sukiko izumikawa who has a
strong passion for photography as a
result of this she always has a camera
in her hand and she is also a member of
the photography club in high school one
day sukiko is returning home with her
best friend Yoshi kazuya throughout the
way she continues to click pictures of
her surroundings as well as of Yoshi a
short while later tsukiko spots her
Elder stepsister Tomi kawakami who also
goes to the same High School Tomi is
currently seen with a guy named toshio
Shinoda a person whom tsukiko secretly
admires this makes her extremely jealous
but she does not let it appear on her
face as Tomi notices them she waves her
hand and requests sukiko to click a few
pictures of her in the midst of this
Tomi says that she knows her stepsister
is jealous of her relationship with
toshio this leaves sukiko speechless
prompting her to stop taking the
pictures seconds later a steel cross
from an under construction building
comes hurling towards Tomi and
penetrates her neck resulting in her
untimely demise Witness this a
shell-shocked sukiko drops her camera
when the camera strikes the ground it
clicks some pictures on its own one year
passes after this incident and we see
that tsukiko's daily life is slowly
returning to normality regardless she
still suffers from grief and recurring
nightmares over her stepsister's death
the scene then cuts to Tommy's 18th
birthday where her parents accompanied
by tsukika sit around a birthday cake in
her honor they sing her a happy birthday
song and celebrate for a while amid this
there is a knock on their door when
sukiku goes to answer it she sees a
creepy Shadow behind the door who calls
herself Tomy this unexpected appearance
deeply on subtle tsukiko leading her to
quickly summon her parents assuming it
to be some kind of prank the father
Musashi opens the door only to be
astonished by the actual return of Tomi
whose Beauty shines even more radiant
than before despite taking some time to
come to terms with this the parents are
Overjoyed to see their daughter alive
and they welcome her back with joyful
tears meanwhile tsukiko is perplexed by
this inexplicable Miracle following
morning she notices an unusual sight
where her father is smelling and even
licking tomi's hair during breakfast
when questioned he asserts that he
missed tell me so much and it is just
his love towards his daughter still
unconvinced by his response tsukiko
steps out into the garden only to
discover her mother burning all the
photographs she had taken she quickly
tries to stop her but Tomi comes in
between sparking a heated confrontation
between the siblings the altercation
ends with Tomic crashing into a wall
seeing this Musashi becomes infuriated
and impulsively slaps tsukiko right away
following this Tomi manages to get
Musashi to whip tsukiko across the back
with a steam iron cable as her
punishment for not showing affection
towards her show your dead sister some
respect yeah now come here let me taste
that hair in the aftermath tsukiko goes
to take a bath and soon after Tomi joins
her eventually the bathroom lights start
to Flicker and as a result tsukiko feels
a bit worried in contrast Tomi has a
creepy smile on her face and soon
proceeds to kiss her stepsister feeling
uneasy tsukiko pushes her away and try
tries to leave but Tomi stops her her
behavior starts becoming increasingly
bizarre and abnormal as she shows
tsukiko the scar on her neck that begins
to evolve into a deranged talking tumor
the sight horrifies tsukiko so she runs
away from what she deems a monstrous
presence hearing this tsukiko's parents
reprimand her and demand an apology to
Tomi at the same time Tomi reappears in
a seemingly normal State wondering how
she could refer to her as a monster she
also expresses that she is offended and
decides to leave the house despite the
parents efforts to stop her Comey
remains Resolute in her decision just
then something takes over Masashi and he
brutally stabs Tommy with a knife
killing her on the spot he instantly
regrets his actions but it is too late
as his daughter is once again dead but
that hair still looks delicious the next
morning sukiko Witnesses a gruesome
scene in the bathroom where her parents
are dismembering tomi's body during this
act sukiko detects a movement in tomi's
eyes startling her for a moment shortly
after the mother disposes of tomi's head
by throwing it away in the trash bin she
then goes to prepare sukiko's school
lunch during lunch she accidentally
drops several chunks of Tommy's flesh
and hair in it while at school the class
teacher introduces everyone to a new
student who Bears a striking resemblance
to Tomy this sends tsukiko into a state
of panic although she manages to
suppress her emotions inside during the
lunch break she confides in her closest
friend about the unsettling events but
her friend dismisses it as mere
perception following this to Kiko opens
her lunchbox only to discover several
miniature heads of Tomi inside
overwhelmed with horror she flees and
throws The Lunchbox into the trash when
Yoshi goes looking for tsukiko she hears
some Eerie sounds from the trash
prompting her to investigate
unexpectedly the miniature Tomi heads
emerge and strangle Yoshi with their
long tongues tragically taking her life
meanwhile at home tomi's severed head
rises from the trash bin and
manipulatively instructs her father to
kill his wife so that she can feed on
her body despite initial reluctance
Musashi succumbs to tomi's influence
back at school toshio approaches tsukiko
and strikes a conversation with her he
expresses his genuine concern for the
difficulties she's been facing lately
hearing him be so compassionate tsukiko
can't help but smile furthermore toshio
who believes that she has a great
photography skill asks her to capture
some images of him during his Judo
practice enthusiastically she agrees to
his request later as tsukiko enters the
Judo practice room with her camera she
begins photographing toshio just then
Tomi shows up out of nowhere and
challenges toshio to a duel the latter
is taken aback to see her alive so he
doesn't respond to her challenge at all
he then attempts to talk to her but Tomi
pretends that she doesn't know him as
the duel begins Tomi effortlessly takes
toshio down and kisses him in front of
everyone after school tsukiko arrives
back home and notices a distressing
scene her father repetitively banging
his head against a pillar when she
questions him about her mother's
whereabouts he leaves without offering a
response later we see Musashi feeding
his wife's flesh to Tommy's head in the
trash bed the following day at school
tsukiko notices toshio passing by her
and then walking away in tomi's company
this deeply saddened tsukiko who then
makes her way to the printing room in
order to print some copies of her
photographs there she encounters her
friend Yoshi who reveals a tumor on her
neck that is similar to the one Tomi
possessed earlier this once again
terrifies sukiko prompting her to flee
the scene Yoshi pursues her and enters
the Judo club's room where she is
confronted by members of the club upon
witnessing the tumor on Yoshi's neck
they immediately decide to cut it off
the group then holds her tight and one
of them proceeds to decapitate it
however they mistakenly decapitate her
head instead of the tumor as everyone
watches in horror the headless body
reanimates and starts pursuing the Judo
club members elsewhere tsukiko comes
across toshio who has seen stabbing Tomi
just as toshio comes back to his senses
a new Tomi emerges from the blood and
begins kissing him this devastates
tsukiko because she feels Tomi is taken
her lover away from her overwhelmed by
emotions she ends up stabbing both
toshio and Tomi to death as she runs
away she is once again chased by Yoshi
whose head has now transformed into the
tumor in the next scene a scared tsukiko
hides in a room locking the door behind
her inside she discovers a small trash
bin from which Tommy's head emerges not
long after another iteration of Tomi
appears from a cupboard her body covered
in blood moreover Yoshi also breaks into
the room and slowly advances towards
sukiko just as she is about to be
cornered by several versions of Tomi she
suddenly wakes up in her bed at home
revealing that everything was just a
dream yeah right I'm relieved tsukiko
then heads downstairs to the dining hall
where her parents are waiting for
breakfast in a completely normal setting
seeing her distressed face they inquire
about the matter in response to Kiko
recounts the nightmare involving her
stepsister puzzled by her words her
parents point out that she is an only
child and never had a sister confused
sukiko searches around for photographs
at real realizes that there are no
pictures of Tomi taking a moment to
relax herself she sighs in relief
believing that she just had a bad dream
unfortunately just after a few moments
tsukiko's assumption turns out to be
false when she sees her father consuming
hair and her mother's head stretching
abnormally to the point where it appears
almost inverted her parents then chase
her prompting tsukiko to run towards the
living room they're a huge reflection of
tomi's face appears in the mirror
calling out tsukika's name at the same
time sukiko's mother approaches her with
a kitchen knife in her hand however
before any harm can be done a
carnivorous centipede made out of
Tommy's head attacks her mother seizing
the opportunity tsukiko decides to dash
upstairs to a room but she is haunted by
the unexpected Encounters of toshio and
Yoshi they cruelly reveal their true
feelings admitting that they never liked
her and were just pretending to be her
friend all along driven by fear and
betrayal tsukiko pushes them down the
stairs after which they are both
attacked by tomi's centipedes inside her
room so Kiko is again confronted by the
looming presence of Tommy's gigantic
head tired of running away she finally
chooses to face her and thus starts
talking to her she inquires about tomi's
real identity and motives in response
Tomy claims that she embodies everyone
sukiko cares for her parents toshio and
Yoshi as well Comey also admits that she
has been taking away all of her loved
ones just to make her suffer and now she
expresses that she needs sukiko's body
and she wants to inhabit her hearing all
of this tsukiko realizes that she will
not be able to survive with all of these
Relentless Visions she then accepts her
fate and decides to fulfill tomi's
desires instead of dying without purpose
as the sisters reconcile that homie
centipedes begin to encroach upon
tsukiko in the aftermath of these events
tsukiko is shown walking out of the
house having become one of the versions
of Tomi wandering through the streets
she finds other women many of them being
tomi's version soon after she runs into
a stranger who asks her to accompany her
to his apartments in the final
tsukiko is in the apartment being
subjected to multiple stabbings by The
Stranger as she lies on the floor She
gazes at a mirror and retains fragments
of her original Beauty however the
reflection she beholds in the mirror is
of Tomi her original stepsister who asks
tsukiko if she is happy the movie ends
as both sisters share a maniacal laugh
their gaze is locked on one another
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching